all right time to see what is trending
here on a friday morning with las vegas
now host mercedes martinez what isn't
trending honestly
good morning mercedes joining us from
the 94.1 studio
hello you guys happy friday about first
up let's talk about superstar lil nas x
fans are really concerned about his
well-being after he has gone m.i.a on
social media the last time he engaged
with fans was back on december 6th so
his last post was on december 17th and
that was deleted saying that he had
covered he tested positive and then that
then it was gone so far there's been no
comment from his representatives also
trending this morning people are leaving
facebook the social media giant lost
more than 20 percent of their value in
just one day they're also seeing about
half a million less logins per day over
the last three months ceo mark
zuckerberg believes that many of those
people are spending more time on other
apps like you john like on tick tock
john heather
dance skills on tick tock are just going
viral every day
you're doing the floss right yeah
yeah whatever whatever that may or may
not be mercedes let's talk about taylor
swift
yeah maybe you are a big taylor swift
fan how would you like to earn your phd
in taylor swift nyu's clive davis
institute is now offering a class on the
pop superstar but if you want to join
it's going to take a little while there
is a very long waiting list the course
breaks down her stardom to give a
broader perspective of pop culture she's
been asked to speak she has not taken
them up on that offer yet but that would
be cool if she did john heather swifties
everywhere trying to get into college
right now yeah get me in there a bs in t
swizzle